Channing Tatum is bringing Magic Mike to
Vegas figured I'd let that simmer for a
minute the 36 year old actor adorably
announced the news Wednesday at the
Hearst new fronts in New York shirtless
men puppies yeah it was pretty epic
what's the next step for magic way 2d
we've done it twice if you built it what
I'm getting at is we're gonna start
Magic Mike live in Las Vegas shortly
after the announcement et spoke with
Channing where he revealed he'll be
involved in the show every step of the
way
yeah casting director we're gonna we're
really we're gonna do it all be weird to
kind of bring somebody else on and
create it and get this if we're lucky we
might even get to see him on stage if
I'm ever in shape enough to do it again
I absolutely will be there I actually
would be really fun and I've got the
clearance from from Jenna as well
and while we feel fortunate to have the
new Magic Mike live show
Channing says he's just thankful for his
family he recently celebrated his 36th
birthday on a camping trip with Jenna
and their daughter ever leave I'm really
blessed man we got we got a little nice
little crazy little family life it's
super simple
Magic Mike live debuts next March at the
Hard Rock Hotel and Casino in Las Vegas